after 5 years of waiting with baited
breath to see if that post credits
teaser was a copout or full commitment
something even Insomniac themselves
weren't entirely sure at the time we
finally have Spider-Man 2 not to be
confused with Spider-Man 2 or Spider-Man
2 entering Electro we finally made it to
the first Spider-Man game where you can
play as both Spidey in a GTA 5es
switching mechanic the first Spidey game
since 200 five where you can play as
Venom and visit Queens New York and the
first Spidey game to get the color of
the costume right but in spite of all
the hype kickass awesome stuff in this
game it's all anchored together on a
story that rubber bands between some of
the best Spidey writing out there two
recycled plot points from other
adaptations that weren't executed well
then and still haven't been now I do
love this game it's easily one of the
best superhero games that we've been
graced with but I can't help but feel
that it's also constructed around a
narrative that's running low on
originality and is rushing through
itself too fast to enjoy in many places
Spider-Man 2 suffers heavily from
insomniac's villain problem thank you
Elijah let's get gameplay out of the way
first I have to give props for the new
additions to traversal like the swing
assist feature and the web Wings first
thing I did was turn the swing assist
down is zero and never look back it
finally has that feeling of momentum
following through from a big swing it's
not as automated and it takes real skill
how easily you showed up fortnite of all
things good work it's actually easy to
screw it up and face plant plus they
added optional fall damage so you have
incentive to get better so you don't
take damage from slamming into a tree at
90 M
hour does Spider-Man need fall damage
despite his superhuman durability and
endurance 60 years of oh no I'm out of
web fluid close call says
yes because this game takes full
advantage of the ps5s hardware there's
no loading time or Draw distance the
entire game map is all loaded in at once
no matter where you are on it so you can
do this ridiculously instantaneous fast
travel or swing as fast as you want
because there's no worry about outpacing
the cold out areas of the map remember
the limitation of the hardware and web
of Shadows where you could swing so fast
that New York wasn't ready to load by
the end of your
Ark that doesn't happen here and not to
mention this is the biggest map in a
Spider-Man game ever you can go to
Queens for the first time since Ultimate
Spider-Man with brookin down there too
that's why you can get thrown 40 blocks
across the island in the middle of a
fight scene and then pull yourself
straight back to combat without a single
popping texture pulling out the web
wings and clearing such huge distances
even over the water is just Insomniac
showing off how much they nailed it and
they've earned that five FSH F there's a
mechanic to catapult yourself long
distances like that thing he does in the
movies all the time you can also hit a
ride on wind tunnels to get extra
momentum that leads into more powerful
swings I enjoy the new mechanic to take
sharp turns around corners without
stopping or slowing down and the Boost
in air Dash help you to maintain speed
when the new cornering mechanic is
whiplash quick you can just fly through
the city now it's so awesome they also
brought back miles's air trick mechanic
from his solo game and it helps you
replenish your ability to do the boosts
and dashes so they incentivize the
player to do stylish and showy moves to
gain more speed it looks cool it feels
cool and it just gives you that sense
that you're fully Unleashed to move like
a superhero this has to be the best
Spidey swinging so far but it's a zero
out of 10 because I can't do that dumb
thing where I shoot two web lines out at
once and then dangle and midair for no
reason this is such a major upgrade and
the first game on PS5 that I've played
where I felt like they managed to
utilize more powerful technology and
justify the exorbitant price I paid for
that stupid looking thing I also love
the Random Encounters that they sort of
brought back from Ultimate Spider-Man
where instead of low-level super
villains spawning in the city you can
just randomly bump into other heroes
from The Wraith to Agent Venom I guess
to even the other Spider-Man really hope
for the third game you can bump into
villains again like the shocker
oh
a he's lucky that Craven got to him
first that's all I'll say miles now
shoots blue lightning from his hands
like a lot of blue Lightning he doesn't
want to be famous and I'll make him
Infamous combat feels so fluid because
the animations have been tweaked to flow
into each other perfectly you get such a
cool feeling from chaining moves
together in such a way that they look
like scripted animations and not offthe
cuff random gameplay play inputs it's a
sight to behold and really increases the
fun of mashing endless criminals I like
using that new bounce mechanic to just
bully individual enemies I wish his face
made that kickball sound though I do
miss the massive amount of gadgets
available in the first game feels like
that element was scaled back to focus on
big power moves like the Symbiote
attacks or lightning blasts from either
Spidey symbiote combat rocks no no it's
this is cool in fact the gadgets are one
of a couple things that seems reduced
compared to the first two games there
are a lot of little features that
weren't completely necessary but were at
least nice to have that are now totally
absent no character bios no model viewer
no social media feed no menu to repeat
podcast audio logs simplified car chases
feels slightly stripped down by
comparison same goes for some of the
optional gameplay content and the
costumes for the former there's a lot
less Variety in the optional missions
and now the vast majority of them are
combat challenges to fight waves of
enemies there's a lot less emphasis on
stealth encounters or skill-based races
or silly puzzles and [__] we all like to
clown on screw ball and Taskmaster for
being lame but they added something
important to the first game that feels
missed here there's this strange sinking
feeling that I have I think this game
needed a few more months of development
because I can see the seams where stuff
was reduced to just get it out on time
and the final product feels a bit lesser
for it I mean even having to wait a few
months for an update to add basic
features once again is frust rating I
also get the sense that maybe some story
stuff got cut because I remember hearing
Dana the Spidey podcaster give this big
rousing speech about the New Yorkers
baning together to saave off the
Symbiote invasion in case the Spider-Man
couldn't handle it we can't leave the
protection of New York just to the
Spider-Man anymore let's be heroes then
we don't actually see much or anything
of how the invasion is actually
affecting New York because the third act
happen so fast then she gives herself
and everyone else a huge pat on the back
for handling all that we survived the
impossible strove back a freaking Alien
Invasion and we did it together as
Heroes the Spider-Man led the way and
every day New Yorkers Rose to the
challenge like what that would feel more
appropriate after playing Web of Shadows
seeing all these survivors battling
hordes of Symbiotes and evacuating
buildings and getting into Shield
Helicarrier Chopper things but there was
none of that here even the Symbiote me
orite as a plot device felt like an
afterthought that was brushed over and I
was just left to assume it worked the
same way as the 2017 cartoon since this
game never sat down and properly
explained it there's got to be a mission
or a cut scene missing to fill that out
it feels incomplete and speaking of
incomplete costumes as soon as they
announced both Peter and Miles were
going to be in the game at the same time
I knew not every suit was going to make
it I was just confused by the ones that
did make it in from the first game
versus the ones that didn't I really
wish they would have kept Peter's
spiderverse suit so I could have had the
boys matching in cutcenes I was really
obsessed with making sure they had
coordinated costumes for a team I also
lament the loss of my old trusty Spidey
armor and bagman was literally created
because of the black costume Saga so
that felt like a no-brainer the backer
building is right there come on Miles
suitless remained pretty untouched
thankfully I appreciate the costume
pallet swaps if only so we could get the
webman and biblically accurate 2099 but
I feel like the fourth slot is always
wasted on some ugly ass mustard yellow
Avengers game looking thing props for
being free though that other game would
have looked you dead in the eye and
asked for $20 for this piece of garbage
and then gotten confused why they didn't
make a profit more like suicide squad
kill your sales I just have to say I
want to openly denounce all these
original costumes from guest designers
and the ones in the pre-order bonus
because most of them are pretty ugly
Power Rangers one is okay I feel like
there's a difference in design ideology
between comic artists who know how to
make something sleek and simple that can
be reasonably drawn multiple times in
sequential art form and game and movie
concept artists who only know how to add
as much detail to something as possible
because detail equals realistic and then
all these just end up being so busy and
ugly and taking up space in the suit
roster I really wish these didn't feel
like they were taking priority over the
comic suits but they do I'd much prefer
those resources being aimed at digging
deeper and getting obscure cool comic
costumes over all this this it's time
for a miles moral is original you
know one of
one it's also pretty insulting to take a
suit that's a brand tie in and try to
make it mandatory for story purposes in
the last few missions of the game I
don't care about whether or not the
Adidas suit looks good I just don't want
a product placement to supersede
Spider-Man's actual costume it's grows
to four force it in into important
cutcenes and disguise it as character
development it' be fine if you threw it
in there as an unlockable to just let
people decide how they felt about it on
their own but don't call that a Miles
Morales original made my guy look like a
doofus in front of the whole city I took
it off the first chance I got every time
until it stops giving you the option
sorry Betsy we have a firm rule against
Spidey endorsements you're a fraud
Spiderman getting a little tired of
mandatory anti-villain suits the anti-g
Goblin suit in the third game should
just be a suit and tie because he's not
going Goblin mode he's going to [__]
work however the original costumes that
are a fusion of a Spidey suit and one of
his villains or Allies like wraith
Mysterio Wolverine Black Panther and
Nick Fury are pretty cool and I'd
happily take more of those in the next
game over whatever the hell this is hey
it's omniac if you're listening the next
thing to add to suit rosters is proper
credit credits and sources like the
Guardians game and you know put Kates
and Stegman in the credits too you only
used all of their symbiote iconography
and lore katees was just in a damn car
accident cut him a check he could use
some help I think of all the major AAA
developers out there Insomniac has to be
one of the best at listening to
constructive criticism and if it's
something with genuine Merit they'll try
to implement it the improvements to the
traversal show that they were aware of
what people wanted more of from a spidey
swinging system and they worked on it
but also improvements like the lowest
Lane stealth missions what was initially
derided as drag on the first game was
something they sought to improve on
she's an important character and cutting
her gameplay out would be the simplest
but least satisfying solution so they
went back to the drawing board and
decided to make it more of an action
third person shooter type deal so
playing as low as Lane is just as fun
and engaging as a spidey Mission she
takes very limited damage so it still
has that feeling of being weak compared
to being a superhero but I think it
works to add some challenge too you can
play these sections stealthily or just
go loud if you're quick enough to not
take damage plus all three of these tend
to be some of the most dramatically
intense moments in the story thumbs up
for that one I just wish that this
character in any way at all actually
resembled Mary Jane Watson in looks or
personality you took a groundbreaking
feminist character the pants in the 60s
wearing untamable free-spirited sex
positive player who dated the entire
coffee bean game
while building up her acting career in
schlocky movies and bad soap operas and
you made her one personality trait that
she's a hot shot reporter that always
gets the scoop I don't even look at this
character model and think Mary Jane I
think Avengers game Black Widow dressed
as Amy
Adams same voice I'm not asking for the
bangs I know it's obvious to do the bang
just go ahead and do some of the
feathered 90s hair give this woman a
cleft chin I dare you and if we're
talking about improvements for
Spider-Man 3 all I've got left left is
I'd like to see that web climbing
mechanic make a return and you really
could try your hand at the web strike
from Web of Shadows since that was
insanely fun and intricate and adding
that on top of everything else you've
got like the craziest Spidey combat ever
again you can kind of do it in this game
but it's just like it's not the same
look at that it's not the same even if
there was a lot of fat trim to make the
release date Spider-Man 2 has a really
insane attention to detail that I got to
admire
I love all these little things like both
Spider-Man have different logos next to
their subtitles to identify which one is
talking the city gets torn up and fights
and then just stays that way and is
progressively cleaned up for several
days in Universe the character models
are so realistic the environments have
so many little Easter eggs and nice
touches and this game is graphically
stunning I also think they managed to
add a few things that were planned for
the original game but got cut before
release like certain lighting conditions
fight animations and mechanics while the
the bulk of the side missions tend to
feel the same gameplay wise they do have
a nice reward with the way they're
written to make it feel like an
achievement I think while it's a shame
that I can see where a lot of stuff got
removed to keep this thing on a timely
schedule the final result from a
gameplay perspective is still a Triumph
of Spidey games they just get better
every time they touch the gameplay and I
love all of the new things that have
been added but video games are also a
storytelling device and in that
regard well the stuff in the open world
is fantastic I've been hearing a lot of
people talk about Jonah and Dany lately
so I might as well throw my two cents in
there since I'll never get the chance
again I really wish Jonah had more time
in these games to be an actual character
and appear in the plot use some stuff
from the zadarski Run maybe where he
becomes Peter's friend and Ally these
games push 30 hours you've got time to
throw it in there but alas his podcast
is pretty much one note jokes popping up
in the open rolled to [__] about Peter
and miles and accused them of the
opposite of what they were actually
doing meanwhile Danica knows way too
much for someone who isn't present for
any of these events like she's
omniscient somehow because we live in
the internet age and Spider-Man trying
on his friend's black suit literally how
do you know that y'all saw the same
footage of Spider-Man I did yeah the way
that new black suit moves how vicious it
is call me worry word if you want but
something ain't right footage from where
who who saw that without seeing Peter
and Harry unmasked I know everyone's got
a cell phone camera these days but this
is stupid nonsense I mean I know there's
a lot of excitement about sm's black is
the New Black look and I mean it is fire
and all but isn't it just a tad Moody
for our friendly neighborhood so and so
OG Spider-Man looks to be finally back
to his senses free of that black suit
it's weird how she keeps popping up to
just explain the plot to you these
podcasts went from nice World building
in the first two games to some of the
worst written dialogue in this one by a
long shot where the story is just being
explained in Cliff Notes as if like
you're playing it but not paying
attention this is how Ken watch movies
with Barbies Danica I swear to God Mary
Jane's podcast is going to be even worse
somehow in the third game this MJ has
the screen presence and Charisma of the
associate manager at Hobby Lobby
Insomniac Spidey writing is a mixed bag
that ranges from to some of the best
Spidey storytelling of the last decade
and this one's no exception I think the
narratives of the side missions fall
into the ladder category and ended up
being Far and Away my favorite part of
the game Insomniac does street level or
small scale stuff with such amazing
finesse and I love how they handle that
side of Spider-Man Mythos across all
three games if it's not part of the main
story line in this one chances are I
love it the side missions range from
epic story lines that feel right out of
the comics character building info dumps
at the end of challenges to fles out
more of the Spidey Rogues gallery or
simple save the cat type stuff that
broadens your connections with the
people of New York there's a really
awesome Mission chain following up on
Yuri Watanabe becoming a lethal
vigilante and butting heads with Peter
about how to handle a guy like Cletus
Cassidy who started his own doomsday
Cult of murderous arsonists as a front
to steal a certain red baby symbiote for
himself they don't reveal that he's us
until like the final part of the mission
but he's wearing a Carnage print shirt
and it's like he's a ginger guy who the
[__] else was he going to be I noticed a
piece of dialogue in my playthrough that
I think shouldn't have been there where
they still call him Cletus even though
that like spoils the
surprise all right Cletus what do you
got I think this is a sound file from
like an earlier draft of the script that
accidentally got left in cuz this game's
kind
of Halo too the more Manson ask take on
Cletus is frankly awesome in the comics
he's always recruiting like-minded
Maniacs to his nihilistic Anarchy
philosophy so this approach is perfect
to give him something to do Beyond just
being a standard serial killer his
personality shines through I like this
design and he's thoroughly established
as a threat even without superpowers
this crazy bastard sets Spider-Man on
fire jeez they may have whiffed it big
time on the other guy but if they follow
through with this one they'd have pulled
off a perfect Carnage I take that as a
nice consolation considering everything
else see I like insomniacs take on
Carnage because he actually talks and
acts like the character Carnage but
beyond that even the more grounded and
downto earth side quests are a joy too
like a flashback to seeing how this
version of Peter became more of a trash
talker in battle when he was young I
like the idea of Jonah being the one who
puts that idea in his head because he's
also such a loudmouth against opposition
miles also has these really really sweet
missions with helping students at his
school saving stolen pieces from a music
museum or getting to spend time with
more of his characters from his solo
game Haley Cooper is such an endearing
love interest because she's a normal
down-to-earth person that doesn't have
superpowers or alternate universe
imaginary adopted children I hope she
becomes a Mainstay for Miles lore
because I like her more than vulture's
grandaughter Hydra Kate Bishop that was
weird stay away from Caucasian girls
with shap heads wearing white hoods
miles they don't want what's best for
you buddy Jefferson Davis was a hero
what the [__] thank God they decided to
use Cindy Moon instead of spidergwen I'm
so sick of spidergwen yeah no one else
uses silk sure that's cool I I respect
that just retool her horribly
embarrassing and convoluted backstory
and you're good to go wouldn't be the
first character they've had to do that
for find grandpa is one of the two most
emotional side missions you encounter in
this game Spidey finds a woman in the
park asking him to help find her
grandfather who got lost out there with
dementia there's no combat very minor
puzzles you find him and sit down with
him and just have a chat with someone
struggling near the end of their life
with sickness and wanting to be with his
wife again the way he give Spidey some
extra perspective from the other side of
a very long journey is very engrossing
reminds him of what's most important to
hold on to in he's youth talking to him
was very personally relatable for me
because it reminded me of both of my
grandfathers my grandpa Vince also had
Alzheimer's and it was really hard
seeing him losing his memory near the
end before he passed away but also the
character Earl looks just like my
grandpa Wesley who moved to the other
side of the country in the last few
years we were close when I was young and
I don't see him as often as I'd like to
now so this made me just miss both of my
grandpas so much and just made me an
emotional wreck and I can't even speak
about Howard just play that for yourself
if you haven't already missions like
these are great for keeping sight of why
being a superhero matters they responded
to criticisms that Spidey in the first
game felt like a cop and now he's more
of a fireman or a first responder
someone who's actually a badass and puts
their life on the line and deserves
respect I like that you can even carry
injured civilians again but now that I'm
not 6 years old anymore I just can't
help but think about how you're ruining
this guy's financial future Spidey stop
your bankrupt ing these people take them
to the hospital instead and by these
people I mean this same wrinkly faed guy
wearing Tims and headphones every single
time do you have any idea the financial
toll that 26 ambulance rides have on a
person the side stuff that isn't based
around fighting enemy hordes is minimal
but still decently fun like collecting
these spiderbots doing Daily Bugle photo
ops or miles looking through prowler's
old hideouts for upgrades the Charlie
bot mission is an unfortunate casualty
of the messy production of a cross the
spiderverse so it culminates in a pants
[__] exciting Cameo from a character
that was cut from the final movie that
we don't recognize at all at least we
know this guy is definitely the one from
the video game and not an adjacent
Universe 12 in to the left boss fights
have improved significantly by just
adding a health bar and really going for
it with the spectacle in these action
sequences that Uncharted style chaotic
destruction with the protagonist being
flung around like a ragd doll is pretty
fitting for Spidey fights on this scale
I said in the first game that I wanted
more epic Chase sequences and this one
really delivered with a lizard fight
this game also has one of the best
traditional black hatat chases so far by
throwing in some Marvel Universe weird
[__] we've come to
expect Felicia is thinking with portals
now I'm very happy to see a life
Foundation symbiote appearance in
2023 when was the last time scream was
in anything the 2017 cartoon the theme
part Dark Ride the boss fights also have
a lot of dialogue and discussion from
the characters to really add some depth
to the fight outside of it just being a
button mashy slugfest it reminds me of
reading a comic where two characters are
saying paragraphs a dialogue mid jump
and superpowered battle you can't keep a
job you can't pay the mortgage I have a
job with Harry we'll be okay and for how
long there's only one job you care about
Spiderman it's a nice touch that just
gives us one more layer of intrigue into
the fight oh I wish this game had the
stones to have Peter and MJ really
discuss these personal issues without a
space alien superhero battle being the
Catalyst it's okay to just do some human
character drama without explosions too
that's something the Guardians of the
Galaxy game was really Adept at just
having slow moments for the game to
breathe and the characters to talk even
the first game felt like it made more
time to have them talk about the
relationship repetitive of the convers
ations may have been there's so much
going on and so many character beats are
really great but they happen so quickly
to get to the next thing the pacing in
this game feels off because stuff like
this is present in the First Act and
then the second and third are too busy
jumping between plot points and major
character beats and it just gets rushed
in quick cutcenes having two Spider-Man
in this game is a really cool idea that
sets this apart from all other open
world Spidey games it almost feels like
two games in one that weave in and out
of each other's stories the only problem
is that miles to half the game is a way
shorter than Peters and B way better
written than Peters Marvel Spider-Man 2
picks up right where the last two
stories left off with Peter and Miles
working together as Spidey and trying to
deal with the difficult work life
balance of being a superhero you're
fired it's nice that Miles initial
missions follow up on the development
from his solo game that his friends and
Community are aware he's Spider-Man it's
an Open Secret and he's still struggling
to live by both lives anyway even if
he's doing a secret identity very
differently from Peter he's trying to
interview for college scholarships while
stealthily taking down a group of armed
kidnappers I really like how both
Spider-Man hit a rough patch where Miles
will drop everything with his personal
life to help Peter in an emergency but
Peter won't give him the same courtesy
Peter's a bit selfish in this game and
prioritizes his friendship and career
Ambitions with Harry over his
responsibility to Miles as his mentor
it's a great setup but I wish they did
more with it and had a real
confrontation about it instead it gets
lost in the shuffle of all that space
alien [__] the city is occupied by
craving the Hunter's gang of mercenaries
and thugs that are helping him look for
a worthy opponent to kill him in battle
they do a great job of building him up
as a genuine threat and as controversial
as it may be I don't mind him killing
some of the smaller Spidey villains like
gargan and Perpetual laughing stock
Electro because there's not much else
you can do with them in this series I
mean it's not like they're going to be
main bad guys but him potentially
killing all of these other guys is way
overboard I do hope the rest of these
villains who weren't directly confirmed
to be dead are still around because it'd
be a shame to have all of these
characters wiped out off screen just to
service another character jeez this
possibly non-cannon room looks like my
office overall though this game's take
on Craven the hunter was pretty great
I'm glad this came out just in time to
save Craven's reputation from being
utterly obliterated in the public eye
like a certain vampire I remember you
Morgan Michaels I know you're still out
there Spidey struggle with wanting
revenge on Mr negative is an interesting
new touch native to this game's universe
and I do like the entire Arc of him
having to make amends with him for the
greater good to save the other Spidey
it's kind of shocking how much better
this version of Martin Lee is than the
one in the comics and hey since all the
puzzle pieces were literally right there
might as well take the opportunity to do
some some anti-venom stuff Mr negative
sacrifices his powers to save Spider-Man
and give Peter the tools he needs to
defeat Venom then pieces off into the
sunset a very nice closer for his Arc
across both of these games it's a fun
idea and it was a clever way to keep the
Symbiote game mechanics involved without
conflicting with the story look at his
disgusting goon
suit there's a really great through line
with all the side villains about
Rehabilitation and putting spidey's
optimism to the test he always argues
that he can't kill his enemies because
they have a chance of changing for the
better they may not always be
superpowered jerk asses that's the major
conflict between him and The Wraith
since she's more of a Punisher type he's
completely right about Carnage though
get that guy in the ground for the
safety of the human race but with guys
like Mysterio lizard Sandman Tombstone
and Prowler it's cool to see all of them
trying to build real lives after they've
been super villains and seeing both
Spidey act supportive of their growth
it's just a shame that this game is so
heavy on super villains becoming good
guys but they drop the ball on the
original Spidey villain turned good guy
molten man obviously where is he at he's
permanently gold and shiny he looks like
a walking
Oscar
o o
corpu the other biggest development at
the start of this game is the return of
the prodal goblin when Harry Osborne is
back in town after being absent for the
previous games his introduction is some
of the best stuff in the first half of
the main story and I really enjoy how
much of this is done through actual
gameplay instead of cutcenes seeing
Insomniac Peter in the year one Arrow
was really cool and it solidified my
opinion that I no longer care about the
face model change I've officially gotten
used to it I don't care anymore it's
fine and after this part of the game I
never really thought about the old model
again all he needs is a better haircut
he kind of looks like Toby with the
ultimate cut in these flashbacks I like
to think that my criticism of the
previous game's character development
with Finn Was Heard because the
flashback mission to childhood best Pals
hanging out and doing casual low stakes
mini Adventures is here at the beginning
of the game instead of near the end
miles and Finn's history was insisted
upon far too late in the game after it
already fallen apart but Peter and
Harry's relationship is shown in great
detail right up front this flashback to
high school Peter is a great way to
endear us to Harry and get a sense of
his character in a fun section that's
still engaging with Spidey gameplay
nothing helps a player build connection
with a character in a game like going
through some [__] together and having
them help you solve a problem it's why
the last of us is still even after
everything more effective as a game than
a TV show we spent a lot of time
together moving boards and ladders
around and just getting to know each
other this is brilliant I'd play a whole
game that's like this Mission Spider-Man
man's Slice of Life it feels like a Side
Story you'd find in a back issue of one
of the side series like web of
Spider-Man or Untold Tales hey Ben 10
hey Ben 10 in the present Harry is
healthy and thriving with the Curative
powers of the Venom symbiote up his ass
after his non-specific D toan disease
from the first game while this version
of Harry doesn't bear much resemblance
to the insecure daddy issues train wreck
college roommate from the comics or the
Contemporary charismatic and womanizing
version we've seen in recent years he's
still a likable character he's just a
lovable sweet guy you'd love to be
friends with him he is so nice he's
really big into science and philanthropy
so he and Pete actually have stuff in
common Beyond being
uh oh God would roller coasters have any
effect on Spider-Man this is a guy who
was basically skydiving for 5 hours a
day every day of his life I kind of feel
like it would lose its luster for him
when he's is always going way faster and
way higher to just like get to work and
stuff I get why Peter loves Harry so
much and this is a really strongly
written friendship they're not worried
about making them both overly masculine
dude Bros with a case of the not gaze
it's a very deep and intimate bond
between two male friends and it's
presented so honestly with so much
vulnerability these guys are as close as
brothers and it shows and I Vibe with it
so
much I love
you I love their relationship in this in
fact they're such good friends that I
have a hard time buying the entire
central conflict that they'd ever be
against each other at
all I I think these two can talk through
anything and for the first half of the
game they do there's such open lines of
communication and such deep trust Harry
accidentally learns Peter a Spider-Man
once the Symbiote makes itself known and
there's no predictable forced argument
for drama they talk it out and
understand each other and they're closer
for it then Harry tries to help out and
there's even more communication and
healthy boundaries set about his level
of involvement in superhero Affairs
Harry's brief stint ripping off Flash
Thompson is a clever Fusion of the
episode and Ultimate Spider-Man where he
took the role of black suit Spider-Man
before losing control of the alien and
some of the early web of Spider-Man
issues where he tried to be a heroic
Green Goblin before going completely mad
I know that that had to be some
inspiration because that was also the
same Arc where Tombstone got his Luke
Cage knockoff powers and Harry and Peter
are chasing after him in the game too
it's the only time I've seen that part
of Harry's Goblin lore ever get an
adaptation so I was actually interested
in those scenes but it was really really
shortlived for the sake of getting the
black suit onto Peter like right away
all the stuff with black suit Spider-Man
albeit really fast is really great you
know it's pulled right from the several
adaptations that are not like the comic
but whatever they streamlined it at
least he has a shape-shifting black
sweater and they remembered to have the
Symbiote fighting crime while he was
asleep H you you ever notied how the
black suit saga's just been kind of like
the same since 1994 but Harry gets left
out of most of the second act and his
entire downfall is relegated to two
cutcenes in between everything else it
just goes by so fast and doesn't feel
developed like conflict with Peter
happening at the same time I never got a
perfect understanding of why he was
angry with Peter in such a way that he'd
become venom the reason shifted in each
scene because the situation just kept
evolving so fast first it's like hey
don't Bogard it dude I'm fully aware
that you're being mind controlled but
you're acting kind of like a dick and
then it's like no you can't destroy it I
need it to not die and those are
perfectly reasonable in the context of
the moment but those happen over the
course of seconds there's also a really
rushed moment to try and throw in the
classic Harry is jealous of Norman's
affection for Peter thing from the Ry
movies but this is the only scene where
they attempt that and it's just not
developed enough to see it as a good
character motivation either it's like
all the elements are floating there but
none of them are focused on enough
individually to form the full picture
the end result makes it feel like Harry
doesn't have a solid genuine concrete
reason to be a bad guy just a handful of
scenes of being like a little bit
annoyed at Peter in the moment nothing
and a friendship over I guess these
scenes have to go by so fast because
even a moment of communication or
rational thinking would smooth it all
over but we need to get to Venom so it's
all a bit contrived all of this hinges
on basically a misunderstanding between
two characters who aren't in their right
mind because one's on mood altering
space alien drugs and the other is so
sick he can barely stand up neither of
them are thinking thinking straight the
entire conflict feels mishandled when it
all comes down to a boneheaded accident
because Harry just panicked oops up
until now they've been on the same page
about literally Everything feels so out
of left field there's no buildup no
Decay they're the best buddies ever then
they disagree for 0.5 seconds and
without really talking about it the
whole city explodes into black tendrils
and Nostalgia baiting gen Z best friends
best friends best
friends this same scene happened in the
all comics in the spectacular show it's
clearly what they're trying to reference
with Peter about to destroy the suit as
Eddie attempts to stop him for a
personal stake in its survival but the
actual disagreement between Peter and
his childhood friend was better fleshed
out so in both cases Eddie's very
deliberate choice to become venom feels
way more earned he did this not for a
desperate bid for survival but because
he's feeling betrayed and angry and we
know very unequivocally why his entire
friendship with Peter has collapsed at
that moment both because he doesn't know
about the mind-altering effects of the
suit clouding Peter's morals and because
Peter genuinely has betrayed their
friendship in a major way that wasn't
affected by the suit at all before that
we spend more time getting to this
boiling point between them so it feels
more interesting to see that choice made
by a character that's taken a drastic
turn after so many things have happened
rather than a quick Act of knee-jerk
clumsiness by someone whose judgment is
impaired oopsie if you want to be a
really nitpicky [__] you could point
out that it's really convenient that the
whole third act happens because
Spider-Man of all characters was unable
to dodge something incredibly easy to
dodge What the fu is this containment
unit made out of porcelain I'm not going
to hang on that but it could have been
executed differently to quell that
stupid logic obsessed Cinema sin's idiot
part of my brain it needed to happen
either way because without it there's
there's no story so what can you do you
know what would have been cool if
Peter's incessant need to keep people
from dying forced him to intentionally
allow Harry to take the suit back to
save his life even knowing full well
what the side effects were because they
had run out of options kind of like in
the Paul Jenkins run when Eddie Brock
died of cancer and Peter intentionally
pushed his body back into the Symbiote
to revive him even though he knew that
it just make them Venom again and rebond
them then Peter could spend the third
Act of the game feeling guilty about
that instead of just being rude in a
situation where he couldn't control the
words coming out of his
mouth I was such a jerk to Harry when I
had that
suit I need to find him
apologize you know like oh man I've
created a monster and all the deaths he
caused are on me instead of just I was a
jerk but yeah I guess after that
slapstick oopsy Harry decides to make
that same choice to take the suit even
though it doesn't have the the same
impact at all and well and now he's
venin you excited look there he venin
got he's Venom just like Bruce Banner's
dad is absorbing
man it sucks so the way it works in this
game is that with both Peter and Harry
the Symbiote tries to give them a
twisted version of their desires I need
this suit it makes be a better
Spider-Man all I wanted was to save
everyone MJ hey Peter wants to be a
better Spider-Man so he doesn't have a
repeat of May's death and Harry wants to
use his Newfound health and power to
make the world a better place to honor
his late Mom the Symbiote uses this
shared feeling of the loss of a mother
figure and drive to do good in both of
them as a way to control them to turn
them into villainous versions of
themselves so once again a dear friend
of Spider-Man has been corrupted to the
dark side this all works on a thematic
level for What Little it does dive into
how the Symbiote thinks but it doesn't
stop this from feeling really similar
even Peter himself seems acutely aware
that this plot is getting scarily
familiar and has a lot of worries that
he'll lose Harry the same way he lost
May and by extension Otto I think it's
smart that they acknowledge the
repetition in the narrative itself but
it does feel like a form of lampshading
because they're still doing pretty much
the same type of villain for the third
time in these games and all this builds
to a new take on Venom that's a new make
in the same vein as Roland emer's
Godzilla yeah I guess it's a giant
reptilian creature that attacks the city
you got the very basic traits right but
like every imaginable other detail that
made him special or cool is wrong it's a
new take though it's a new take where
the cool parts are gone that's the new
take that's what's new about it is we
took the cool stuff out this is what you
get when you treat Venom like a plot
device and not really an actual
character it is not Eddie Brock okay it
is not it is not Edie BR um our goal was
to tell an original story something you
haven't seen in the comics of the movies
yet obviously wow we expecting me to
start whining about Eddie Brock by now
oh but Eddie Brock Eddie Brock we had 5
years to wrap our heads around the fact
that they weren't going to use him and
plenty of other characters can be Venom
too if it's handled well doesn't make
the execution of the story they did tell
any better I could probably go through
this whole review without even talking
about him honestly him not being here
the least of this story's problems all
right just because you've been good this
year and you're on my nice list I'll
serenade you with that irritating Spiel
let's talk about 19 Ines of missed
opportunities okay I'm not one of those
YouTubers this isn't one of those bad
faith Fanboy things where the complaint
is just that a minority has an important
role in the story they replace not one
but two of my favorite straight white
guys with another straight white guy
okay well the jury's out on Eddie being
straight he gives gives fruity Vibes
sometimes a lot of times which just
makes me miss him all the more I was so
on the money about this in 2020 I may as
well just play the same clip again since
my opinion hasn't changed I'm noticing a
concerning pattern with insomniacs
villains they seem to be doing that
thing from bis's Ultimate Spider-Man in
the Ry movies where every major
antagonist has a personal connection in
history with Spidey before becoming the
main bad guy now you don't have to write
them an origin story and have Spidey
build a relation ship with them after
they meet for the first time he's just
coincidentally known them for years
obviously the majority of the Sinister 6
are exceptions to this but with Martin
Lee Doc O and now the tinkerer it looks
like all the main villains will follow
this formula and honestly I feel like
that's going to get old really fast I
get it it's a cheap and easy way to tug
at the old heartstrings when the main
opposing force is an old friend that
lost their way but it's going to get
repetitive if they do that a third time
in a row I have this sinking feeling
that once again for Marvel Mar
Spider-Man 2 Peter's old bestie Harry
Osborne will be Venom and we'll get the
whole but the main bad gu is my bro I'm
so conflicted scenario which we just saw
twice try something else please not
every villain needs a deep personal
connection to the hero they can just be
a bad guy who mirrors our hero by having
an opposing ideology and an interesting
backstory or motivation Thanos wasn't
Tony Stark's roommate from college who
became jealous of his success Wilson
Fisk isn't Matt murd childhood best
friend that went down a dark path keep
in mind a bit of this is also coming
from the fact that I'm a huge Eddie
Brock fan and I don't want them to
forget about him because I want to see
how they'd handle that character but at
this point I'm just waiting for the
moment in a future game where Peter is a
boss fight for Miles either because he's
wearing the black suit or because he's
got o brain oh no my former mentor and
best bud oh no meanwhile gy becomes the
new hobgoblin and Frames Ned Leeds as
revenge for confusing casual fans wow
I nailed that one so far in advance I
mean it's you know just because it's
really predictable and obvious even from
years ago but yeah I'm sick of the
formula it's not just a problem with
these games it's basically every
Spider-Man adaptation ever at this point
you guys hate variety that much Sandman
can't just be a criminal with a Secret
Heart of Gold he has to be the one who
shot Uncle Ben Dr Connors is friends
with Peter's parents and needs their
notes to finish his lizard juice it all
dates back to Doc O being Peter's
science camp Idol it's ironic that this
problem only started to get out of
control with Eddie Brock and has gotten
so bad over the years that it's now
erased him from his own origin story
this is one of the few things I think
MCU Spider-Man is actually good at none
of these villains knew Peter Parker
before the movie started they're not
longtime family friends former business
partners or an old Mentor in his
schooling days or a childhood friend and
no way home he met Green Goblin earlier
that same day and that guy changed his
life forever and brought the devil out
in him a compelling hero and villain
Dynamic does not need to hinge entirely
on shared history sometimes we can do
something different it won't kill you to
break the mold and stop adhering to this
same friend turn foe pipeline it starts
to get ridiculous when every normal
person Spider-Man interacts with in his
day-to-day life is liable to get
superpowers and try to kill him later on
at this point I feel like the third game
will be about Peter's nextdoor neighbor
Roger transforming into a mechanical
acid spitting wasp and burning his house
down please try something new get
creative I'm on my knees begging to not
do the same story a goddamn fourth time
in a row I mean how could you at this
point surely they can't dear God the
reason I wanted Eddie Brock so badly is
because he's the exact opposite of this
Trope look Parker and I have a
complicated history but it's water under
the
bridge oh well I guess we're still
building that bridge but we have bigger
fish to fry from the gear Bridge well
you know in the the good comics where
he's not a [__] creep he's a down on
his luck guy who created a lot of his
own problems in life by not taking
responsibility for his actions he's
trying to recover from an abusive
childhood and a lot of his selfish
actions caused his marriage to fail then
he has this pretty one-sided rivalry
with Spider-Man that turns so ugly it
eats him up inside until he becomes the
worst version of himself okay well maybe
not the worst version of himself he gets
all the power he could ask for and the
Symbiote feeds on his denial and
negativity to turn him into a weapon of
its own Revenge you're free you can stop
this stop hating it only loves
me for the hate he's the ultimate hater
because he's being manipulated to the
point of being completely delusional but
he rests control back from the Symbiote
and regains his composure and his
humanity and then he gets to know Peter
like really know him not just the
Twisted facts the Symbiote fed him to
keep him riled up they become begrudging
allies then eventually they form a real
connection he realizes he was being
manipulated to farm hate into this
jilted alien exir girlfriend and he
decides to take charge and use its
powers to be better he forces both of
them to evolve into something greater
and it was a long uphill battle but by
God he made it because Peter never gave
up on him and wanted him to redeem
himself always wished I'd had a strong
friend who could save me from the
monsters in my life so I became a
monster to save those too small to fight
for
themselves yeah they might be afraid of
me but
I'll keep them safe he's a villain who
hates Spider-Man so deeply at first but
one day after a lot of pain becomes
Peter's friend that's compelling to me I
find that interesting he's Vegeta and
Kevin 11 before those guys were even a
thing and a lot of shades of that were
used with Harry here but just uh don't
tell me it's the same it's not the same
but the years have corroded the public
perception of Eddie Brock's importance
so that now the character isn't
considered necessary first Eddie gave up
being Venom in the comics for like 14
years and his storyline started to fade
from memory then the Ultimate Comics
used him in an at the time interesting
new format that was then copied
endlessly for every other antagonist and
he was forgotten by the book itself he
disappeared and the synthetic symbiote
kept showing up without him now we have
people who grew up with ma gargan as a
flat boring Monster version of Ven that
had nothing interesting to do ever then
Flash Thompson is the admittedly super
cool anti-hero equivalent to Spider-Man
and then what do we do with Eddie okay
we'll just make him anti-venom uh I
don't know that's not panning out the
way we wanted it to okay now he's toxin
uh now he's agent toxin I don't know
whatever it Eddie just didn't matter
during those years and Circa 2015 when
Insomniac got the rights to Spider-Man
games and began plotting their Trilogy I
can forgive that they didn't think he
mattered at the time either they looked
at what was recent and rolled with that
he hadn't had his big return the
legendary Donnie Kate's run in his
Blockbuster movie series yet he hadn't
shown us why he's the comeback King yet
this was worsened by the Ultimate
Spider-Man animated series cutting him
out entirely in the 2017 cartoon using
him as a minor Cliff note and keeping
the Symbiote front and center without
him for most of it then the movie tried
to simplify things by just saying Venom
is the alien instead of the host and the
Symbiote together I am
Venom and you are mine and that [__]
everything up I noticed that you
sometimes refer to yourself as we why is
that Venom isn't a singular personality
It's a combination of myself and the
Symbiote that's why we say we been an
unfortunate compounding effect of
adaptations asserting that Venom is
solely the black sludge and the person
inside can just whoever sidebar the
Symbiote that makes the new red Goblin
is called Rascal so a precedent has been
set that the goo name can be different
from the superhero character name a lot
of people in the Phantom refer to Cletus
Cassidy Symbiote as red because he
called it that one time so I'm going to
put forth an idea someone may have
suggested this before in the last 30
years but I'm taking credit for it I I
don't I don't know who the hell you are
this guy right here this entity this
thing we've seen it a bunch of times its
Canon name should just be suit instead
of Venom or unpronouncable vibrational
frequency Eddie the
suit you got to take it off I saw the
suit you heard me yes the suit you've
got to crawl in this when you get the
suit back so many characters already
call it the suit in universe and it can
help distinguish Venom from just being
the goo by itself take it or leave it
but that's what I'm speaking into
existence until it sticks so anyway
people don't think Eddie is important
anymore even though he's like the entire
thing Eddie's the reason they call
themselves Venom we are poisoned to
Peter Parker and
Spiderman we're Venom now we're poison
to you Spider-Man that's why we call
ourselves then people who don't read the
comics don't know about his Redemption
Arc all they've gotten from the majority
of the adaptations is that he's just a
one note angry villain when that's
ironically the least interesting thing
the character has ever been he's evolved
past that and becomes something so much
cooler that can stand perfectly fine on
his own without surfacing Spider-Man
he's like 250 issues into his solo book
and Spider-Man barely shows up in that
but he's only really gotten one
adaptation that ran the full gamut of
his transformation from a jerk to a
vicious Tormentor to a remorseful hero
the rest either stay focused on his
anger and don't explore him any further
or just jump straight to him being an
anti-hero without giving him much depth
the Venom movies captured the zany
personality and off-the-wall tone of
classic Venom Comics well but Eddie
himself is the weakest part of those
because they don't dig too deep into
that Darkness or psychology of him it's
not like we're drowning in comic
accurate adaptations of this character
so it's fair to say I'm disappointed
that yet another one dropped the ball by
not even attempting the hard parts once
again works for me Shake on it oh wait a
sec put her there
partner I'm there partner I really
wanted to see how Insomniac would write
that character but that wasn't the story
they were interested in telling and I
don't even think it was the one that
they were planning to in the first place
they took the easiest way out stuck with
their formula did something predictable
and that's a bummer we love venom for a
reason yeah all those things you love
about the character going to be there
it's reductive and silly to get mad at
anyone for being dissatisfied with how
Venom is handled here I know he's a big
cool scary monster that has tendrils and
eats people's heads whatever yeah like
he's fun to play as and he looks like
Venom but all the aspects of the
character that I like aren't here he has
no personality he doesn't act like Venom
he says like one line of dialogue in the
whole game that sounds like something
Venom would say thanks for coming peep
if you can't imagine your Venom chanting
surf the web or delivering this speech
eyes lungs and
pancreas so many snacks so little time
then you just didn't do Venom if you
watch my videos you know I appreciate
comic accuracy when it's done well but
that's not the be all and all sometimes
I even Advocate that changing the source
material's weaker aspects can benefit an
adaptation greatly you can change events
add characters cut characters rearrange
plot points or combine multiple story
lines together plot isn't the only thing
that matters it's just a structure of
events that can be rebuilt you don't
need to introduce the suit during Secret
Wars or have the Fantastic 4 analyze the
suit or have Peter get nabbed by a
passing member of a gang called the vuan
or any of that crap change that as much
as necessary streamline it please go
ahead doing the black costume Saga with
the other Spider-Man Pres in itself is a
really awesome change and I love that
aspect of this game story a lot that was
cool stuff some changes are great dis
SKU the limit as long as the heart of
the character is the same I just want
their personalities intact is that too
much to ask otherwise it's not even the
same character just an empty costume
without Brock this take on the Symbiote
is just a generic evil monster of the
week bent on world domination been there
done that it might as well be a scroll
or Fin Fang fom or The Brood then
Venom's not about being a conquering big
bad restoring the Symbiote race he's not
Zed while I like the character way more
as an ally to Peter Parker even his
super villain game was more complex than
just doing another Alien Invasion plot
he's a stalker that feeds on Peter's
paranoia he attacks him in broad
daylight out of costume to keep him on
his toes Spider Sense is useless he
shape shifts and blends into the crowd
or turns entirely invisible he grins a
gnarly toothy smile outside the window
he's always watching you're never safe
Venom even shows up to Peter's front
door and makes small talk with Aunt May
just to make him anxious about a fight
breaking out or his secret identity
being revealed I guess Harry tried to do
that but he didn't have the same smug
bastard energy and he was just more
there to oo a liquid sample of his
offspring on MJ's chest don't look at me
like that that's literally what happened
Eddie as Venom knows Peter just a little
too well and plays on his biggest fears
and the worst part is that he does all
this thinking he's justified in taking
on a bad guy you know nothing about us
but we know everything about you you'll
see us everywhere even in your
nightmares and we want to dismantle you
peace by peace we know who you are and
everyone you care about imagine them
working all that into gameplay making
the city feel unsafe for the player
because any NPC on the street could turn
into spider Nemesis and knock you on
your webbed ass without Spider Sense
indicators to help you [__] him and
miles can both turn invisible you could
do something with that no one ever
remembers that Venom can straight up
turn invisible too but now he's just a
xenomorph Queen birthing hundreds of
drones so you can in turn punch hordes
of sludge monsters and go
wow it's like 2008 all over again when
two games like this came out in one year
hey look we're fighting in literally the
exact location from that other game yeah
I know I'm the Target demographic for
that Nostalgia [__] I don't care his
Twisted sense of humor his moral code
his hatred and Redemption are all the
parts that make venom noteworthy among
Spider-Man Rogues and allies now he's
been Whitted down to a one-dimensional
costume that can be thrown on anybody to
take over the world the magic is gone
it's just a Mas that's laid on the head
of any random character that Peter
Parker considers an acquaintance
unfortunately this is the least
interesting thing you could do with
Venom but it's becoming the default this
isn't a new take on Venom it's just a
mashup of stuff from the previous two
cartoons and web of Shadows which also
had an underwhelming Venom until like
the last 5 minutes of the game why is
Harry doing this creating all these
things I don't think Harry's the one
doing it at least not the Harry I know
then who is
the Symbiote yeah Harry is infected with
the Symbiote but the Symbiote ends up
being like the totally dominant half
that's on Earth to Herald the Symbiote
Invasion while the host is helplessly
playing along as like a meat puppet I'm
not hating on it because it's an
accurate to the source material it's
really accurate to these animated shows
that I'm not a huge fan of but if you
give me the v252 we can create something
wonderful together it's just not as
fresh and new as we were sold on and the
execution Lacks impact all Harry
contributes is a pair of legs so the
Symbio could stand upright and a pair of
hands to punch with could have been m
gargan in there since he's just as Bland
as Venom what do you want revenge for
why do you call yourself Venom doesn't
matter here's that character design you
like because he looks cool he's just a
big action figure now the personal
connection with the villain thing is
watered down by the fact that Harry's
not even in control don't let him get in
your head that's not Harry talking Harry
man that's the CIO talking not you Venom
is pulling words from Harry Osborne's
mind and talking on behalf of him with
all this Heal the World and Harry's
jealous of Miles stuff to give the
illusion of any character motivation but
that final boss makes it clear that
Harry isn't actively trying to hurt
people
he he what's happening just hang on
buddy please no leave him
Al plus we played as Peter with the suit
we know how it works he's also got the
Candyman voice in his head telling him
to kill everything kill Cen
K he's just a victim along for the ride
like the Myriad of hosts in the 2017
cartoon wrong this is the real me and
the scene with him acting evil earlier
was the same angsty brain addled mind
control that Peter was under and MJ was
immediately after I am in complete
control what's happening to
me this game's very explicit that the
things you do Under the Symbiotes
influence are out of your control does
all this evil stuff for you and makes it
seem like your idea even if you'd never
actually do any of those things so at
his core Harry doesn't want any of this
just like MJ didn't actually want to
shatter Peter's
tailbone it's out of his control and
that makes for a weak villain he's an
inactive antagonist being steered around
by a boring generic monster with no
personality that says boring generic
monster dialogue like join us join us so
I just have like nothing to latch on to
this is a lame villain Otto and Finn
both at least were completely of sound
mind and aware of their actions when
they broke Spider-Man's heart and it was
developed across a much longer span of
time in Otto's case so none of this
really hits as hard as the previous two
games they did the same thing three
times in a row and this is the weakest
laziest version of it not that anyone
cares but the suit being behind the
invasion is completely out of character
for it too it tries to stop things like
this from happening they did King in
black but made Venom the bad guy instead
of null as much as I love Donnie Kate's
Venom run null isn't exactly a deep
character
it's like they read arguably the
greatest Venom story of all time and
decided to ignore the actual story and
characters and just use the Aesthetics
alone because it was recognizable I'm
not impressed by the spirals and dragon
wings if it has no real substance and is
just purely visual fan service this is
the most surface level and uninteresting
Venom adaptation thus far oh but I want
Venom to be dark and mean and
threatening to the whole world he should
be a menacing villain that's serious and
brings the Symbiote invasion you want
the movie version of Riot you're
thinking of Riot these games need to
stop having Venom act like Carlton
Drake's Riot how easily you were outdone
by midnight sons of all
things you're
welcome
cute I mean all right I like Harry
Osborne as a character I just vastly
prefer the version of him that's a
recovering addict having to live up to
his father's massive expectations or
battle his demons knowing that he's the
son of a crazy super villain Harry is
the best Green Goblin in the comics even
outshining Norman that's gotten exactly
one decent adaptation the movies botched
it twice but for some reason the Dane
danan version was their go-to in these
games for like his backstory and Fall
From Grace you're a fraud
Spiderman now him and Eddie are both
lesser for taking this route just missed
opportunities on top of missed
opportunities there's nothing this story
did with Harry's Venom that couldn't
have also been accomplished with him
Juiced up with the healing properties
and mental toll from Goblin formula and
infecting other New Yorkers with that
like goblin war uh but the Symbiote is
cooler looking and more popular and
people remember from those other games
Hey look it's like Web of Shadows but
happening way too fast I'm not opposed
to other people than Eddie Brock being
Venom in cases like Flash Thompson it
can be amazing but in my opinion this
game didn't execute it well enough to
justify doing it at all and he only
appears in the last hour of the game to
barely get any development or screen
time do I think this game would have
been improved by making it Eddie instead
actually no fck no I think that would
have been completely antithetical to
what they were trying to achieve with
this story as much as I love that
character and find him important they
couldn't have made him work for the
story they wanted to tell here which is
again why I wish they hadn't sacrificed
Venom as a way to build up a story that
could have been achieved perfectly fine
with something else something more
fitting and dramatically interesting for
Harry you didn't have to drag Venom down
for this it was totally
unnecessary you could spend an eternity
picking a part little Fanboy
inaccuracies like vulnerability to Fire
or the location of the bells ringing or
whatever but what matters is the
characters and they forsook that to tell
a story that wasn't completely
satisfying even on its own terms the
entire inclusion of Venom is rushed
underdeveloped derivative and the
biggest sin is just not giving Tony Todd
better material to play with he's got
like the most perfect Venom voice
possible but it's wasted on such serious
and cliched L lines let the man sing
Strangers in the Night or talk about
heating brains if they do end up making
a Venom spin-off game they have to bring
him back and write him some fun stuff to
say full stop I can't let such amazing
casting go to waste you really got that
man in the booth to use 8 minutes of
dialogue in a 25-hour game weird I just
finished a film about an undead soccer
team and it was called
shinpads oh wait that was Final
Destination five that skank wasn't worth
the
$4 I'll spin on an ice cream con as for
the rest of this cast they acted the
[__] out of this okay it best script for
the main story I've never seen a game
where the vocal performances did such an
amazing job of elevating material that
at times can be pretty mediocre everyone
was in top for Yuri my boy I think
you've secured your place as my new
favorite Spidey voice actor cuz you're
really went for it in every scene won
best performance in my heart even if the
Oscars don't recognize video games come
on back pal let's do more benen
Shenanigans even though I just spent
like 30 minutes crapping on Spiderman 2o
it's okay oh he's cool about it we're
already starting to get hints that this
game had a troubled development behind
the scenes and tons of Concepts got cut
levels got removed or whole lengthy
segments of story were truncated and
it's unfortunate that it show is in the
final product if I had to guess it could
be that Sony forced Insomniac to tie it
off and put it out so they'd have a
major release this year part of me
wishes that this game got delayed for
another year or more so they had more
time to implement all their ideas
without having to Crunch CU crunch just
makes everything suck for everyone Web
of Shadows had a lot of cut ideas too
but that game still felt like a more
Complete product and like they got their
bang for their buck with the Symbiote
Invasion concept by pacing it out more
slowly and making it feel like it was a
problem for the whole Marvel universe
that one felt like watching a zombie
apocalypse but with Spider-Man as the
main character this game's third Act is
so quick and underdeveloped that feels
visibly incomplete take your time I can
be patient I'm aware that I'll be in my
30s when you release the third one I'm
fine with it just slow down let it cook
because I'm decent at predicting things
here's all the side villains I think
will be in the third game come back in 5
years and let me know if I was right
with Peter taking a semi hatus from
Superhero work as he often does in the
comics I think it'd be nice to take a
break before Spider-Man 3 and do uh
Spider-Man Miles Morales 2 because he
was a bit of an afterthought in this
story compared to Peter while it is like
the best part of the main story his Arc
with Mr negative wraps up a good long
while before the game ends and he
doesn't have much else to do outside of
chasing that one threat or just reacting
to whatever Peter's half of the story
has caused it feels weed a bit too much
towards classic Spidey and I don't want
him to get sidelined and put in that
terrible costume for long maybe we can
have him take the lead on the DLC in
battle Carnage or something remember
that book in absolute Carnage that they
forgot to finish so there's a giant
unresolved Cliffhanger in that series
Good Times yeah you can put that costume
in as a DLC Spider-Man 2 is a very mixed
bag with some parts that were really
engrossing and groundbreaking scenes
mechanics and set pieces that have to be
some of the best of the last decade of
gaming but it's also tied together with
a story that feels tired and fails to
meet the mark and it's clear that this
game was meant to be much bigger and
more polished and I feel like Insomniac
really is just adapting mostly other
adaptations and can't find a way to put
their own original spin on anything
without it coming across really
syy you got one idea and it's not even
like your idea but you keep doing it
it's a game that goes from Spider-Man 3
to web of Shadows to Ultimate Spider-Man
in its plot but it doesn't have very
much about it that I can go wow that
reminds me of Marvel Spider-Man 2 it's
not doing a fresh and modern take on
comic stories it's just compiling bits
and pieces of the cartoons games and
movies that already did that to begin
with so you get this unfortunate effect
of it all feeling like secondhand ideas
I've seen all of these Concepts reused
recycled reimagined and repackaged so
many times like a game of telephone
that ironically just doing something
from the original books would now
actually be more unique and refreshing
can you imagine a single Spider-Man
adaptation where he dates Betty Brandt
first or where he's the one who corrupts
the initially peaceful and benevolent
symbiote with his shitty attitude
instead of the other way around how
about someone really taking a genuine
shot at Harry's drug problem instead of
making silly metaphorical Illusions to
it with fictional Super V meds as a
standin what if we saw Peter's bully
turned friend Flash Thompson used for
more than just jokes and have to
actually grapple with the realities of a
life-altering disability and still
become an amazing superhero despite said
disability can J Jonah Jameson be an
actual character again instead of just
grouchy comic relief so many great
things about these books really only
exist in adaptations now as cameos
Easter eggs and running gags I want you
to remember this forever forever if a
movie director or TV writer or game
developer says they're taking
inspiration from classic Spidey stories
they always exclusively mean the 9s
cartoon if they say they're pulling
something straight from the comics they
mean Bendis ultimate or slot ASM and not
a damn thing else the entire
entertainment industry adapting
Spider-Man stories into other mediums
would rather die then use any full
storylines by JM D matus Jerry Conway
Tom DeFalco Peter David J Michael
trzinski David molini Chip zadarski Mark
Wade or even Stanley himself the best
you'll get is
tangential maybe even unintentional nods
or inspiration for a scene or two that
was gleaned off of skim read of a
Wikipedia article and then that scene
would be in a completely different
context we could be getting so Much
Death depth and so much unused material
from spidey's golden years I mean those
books are in the dumpster right now but
if there's not like 40 years of good
stuff to use too but instead we're still
getting hung up on these and it's pretty
much the only thing we ever see anymore
in Peter Parker stories if they aren't
Multiverse related they've done the
friend turned enemy parlor trick to get
you emotionally invested so many times
that it no longer works I can see the
strings I'm not impressed anymore
Spider-Man 2 also has a bad habit of
wasting characters to build up other
ones like killing tons of super
criminals to make Craven look more
threatening or botching four of spidey's
Best Supporting characters to create an
underwhelming sloppy hodg podge of them
that sadly has none of the interesting
parts of any one of them Insomniac Venom
is their weakest main villain so far and
I feel let down that Harry and the
Symbiote didn't live up to their full
potential as
characters H Norman's reason for hating
Spider-Man is pretty forced and dumb But
Otto is written so well in this series
that hopefully his involvement can
salvage it next time I have hopes though
that Norman Osborne and Otto Octavius
teaming up for the third game will
finally lead to something different we
can't retread that same old [__] again
with that setup and I have a feeling
they were saving their best for last so
while it feels like a great evolution in
gameplay from its predecessors it feels
like a step down in quality of
Storytelling and like a throwaway middle
chapter before getting to the big finale
this is the Halloween kills of
Spider-Man
games and that's that's
rough I always get mad at YouTube for
not putting my videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist
if you want other ways to support the
channel you can always go hit up that
patreon for early videos and exclusive
stuff because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only $1 Isn't that cool if
everyone who watched this video donated
$1 a month I'd be able to afford a house
for myself so that would be that would
be really cool you can also check out
our merch on tuu or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator code
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dance or a cool character skin really
helps me out see you next
[Music]
time